[Music]
it's got to be very satisfying for you
because
you hear this story a lot in this town
you've had this tremendous success and i
i think you have a three-year contract
now and things are going very well it's
good to have a job it's good to have a
job but like many people you really
struggled here in los angeles when you
got started out didn't you yes i did uh
my favorite part of that whole
uh three year span
uh was uh not having a car
in los angeles how could you have no car
now well i had a car i came here in a
car yeah uh from you came from st louis
from st louis missouri home of the
cardinals home of the blues
um enjoy yeah that's fine that was the
dog yeah
the dog is a huge hockey player
yeah and uh and i was dispossessed of
the car by the city of los angeles uh
why did they take your car uh i would
accumulate parking tickets
unfortunately that's a hobby it's a
hobby
you're a collector other people's stamps
sure you parking party tickets they're
so colorful yeah um
unfortunately they also come with fines
and i didn't have a job or any money
so i would let them sort of backlog and
at a certain point
they decided just to take my car
uh so the the city came up with a little
tow truck and uh away my car what kind
of car was it it was an 86 toyota
corolla nice
uh and i had accumulated enough parking
tickets to where those were worth more
than the car yeah so so that's when you
don't even fight it so how do you get
how do you get around los angeles with
no cars well i don't know if you know
this but the city of los angeles has a
wonderful
public transportation system
i don't think anybody knows that no
that was part of the debt i have to
repay the city of los angeles
for the rest of your life i rode the bus
and uh and then when i would get near
where i needed to go i would rollerblade
no
you would rollerblade there is nothing
there is not a worse look in the world
than a dude
skating down highland avenue
to an audition
to try and sell soap
[Laughter]
roll seriously
sweaty and stinky
skate's on i'm here
no it's
i'm here
so did you ever ever ended up getting a
car after that or no it's almost taken a
long time uh i ended up uh somebody gave
me a car that was such a terrible car
yes that instead of attempting to sell
it they just went here yeah uh and that
was in 1981 i was regressing uh
volkswagen rabbit that was convertible
but the reason it was convertible is
because the top didn't work
uh
it also had the unique feature of the
driver's side seat was held up by a
piece of particle board wedged
into the back
so you kind of have to drive
this
uncomfortable piece of wood
sticking you in the back
and it didn't have a gas gauge we all
had cars like that i had a
1977 isuzu opal that i literally got for
nothing same thing where someone just
said take it it's better i don't want it
in my yard anymore and the worst part
was there's a terrible car but it had an
eye heart my and then the face of a
poodle on the back
and i tried everything to get that
sticker off and i couldn't and people
were like you've got a poodle
no i don't well you should have got a
poodle yeah
i did